Hi, I'm Adam, a researcher working on the
extension system for Google Chrome.
In building the extension system, we've designed
in security from day one. Security has many
facets, but in this video, I'd like to focus
how the extension system makes it easier for
developers to create secure extensions.
The security architecture is based on two
principles: least privilege and privilege
separation.
Extensions get only those privileges requested
in their manifest. For example, the Gmail
Checker extension declares that it wishes
to interact with Gmail. Because it does not
request access to your bank, Gmail Checker
is not granted access to your bank.
Now, least privilege does not protect you
from malicious extensions. If you install
a malicious extension, all bets are off, just
like when you install a malicious program
on your computer. Instead, least privilege
helps if an honest extension has a vulnerability.
If somehow, an extension is compromised, the
attacker's privileges will be limited.
As you develop extensions, you should request
only those privileges your extension actually
needs, reducing your attack surface and helping
protect your users.
In addition to least privilege, the extension
system encourages privilege separation. Instead
of lumping all their code together, developers
divide their extension into two pieces: a
background page, and a content script.
The background page is given the lion's share
of the extension's privileges but is isolated
from direct contact with web pages. On the
other hand, content scripts have direct contact
with web pages, but have fewer privileges.
If a content script is compromised, the attacker
doesn't get all the extension's privileges.
To steal all the privileges, the attacker
has to exploit a second vulnerability, such
as a cross-site scripting vulnerability in
the background page.
We've designed security into the Google Chrome
extension system from day one. Using least
privilege and privilege separation, we've
helped developers reduce the attack surface
of their extensions.
To learn more about Google Chrome's extension
system, visit our website at code.google.com/chrome/extensions